all over Australia and what are you
hearing about the strikes today I it is
just incredible to see all this last
night before I went to bed Australia and
the Pacific island nation started to
strike so that it was the first I saw
and I was able to see that already
looming before and then tonight when I
know this morning when I woke up there
were I mean just everything had just
blown out of proportion that was just so
much everywhere and the numbers I hear
are incredible
even the like fresh numbers I hear was
1.4 million people striking only in
Germany and about 400,000 in Australia
of course these aren't numbers aren't
confirmed with just things I hear and
it's I'm so pleased with everything in
it's just such such a victory
it's obviously exceeding your
expectations when you started this who
ever think you'd get numbers like this
no never this was this could only be a
fantasy I would never have predicted or
believed that this was going to happen
someday and and so fast in only a few
months it's and this this is I think I
can say to say that this is the biggest
global time and strike bigger than the
loss at once so we will just see I can't
wait to see all the all the official
numbers come in it will be magnificent
do this
I mean of course marches like these
won't do any concrete actions I mean it
won't change everything but it's still
it's such a strong message and I think
that if enough people go together and
stand up for for this then that can have
a huge difference both in the social
social differences social tipping points
but also to put pressure on the people
in power and to make them to actually
hold them accountable and to say you
need to do something now
it's given a political situation here
what is your impression of the situation
here I feel like it's of course it's
it's a bit worse than in other countries
but basically it's it's the same
everywhere
it's the arguments for in for continuing
to do not do anything are the same and
the empty words of promises and lies are
the same and it's just even if of course
it's differs from country to country
some countries are more extreme than
others but it's I mean it's not much
different but it's
I don't know what's the worst I've seen
that depends on how we define for the
worst
tomorrow is a song even was today we be
telling
tomorrow I won't have an official speech
I will just participate because I'm
speaking later so so I don't need to
speak more than I'm already planning to
do the leaders will see you out
yeah and I will just tell them - I mean
refer to the science and tell them you
need to listen to the science and you
need you to take your responsibilities
and - to actually to take the measures
required
is probably the most efficient
I don't know if this week a result and
everything in anything we we must hope
but we we must also be prepared for for
that nothing comes out of it and then we
need to continue no matter what because
giving up cannot be an option so but
indeed this is a great opportunity to we
could actually accomplish something
worldly this could actually accomplish
something because they have this
opportunity to to do something and they
should take that and otherwise they
should feel shame
I think I'm about the same optimises now
as one month ago because of course
things are continuing to happen and with
this strike and everything and that the
climate crisis is more on the agenda but
still a month has passed since then and
the emissions haven't drastically
reduced so we so it's
yeah I don't know I'm the same as before
your generation years
I have no idea how bad it will be when I
am an adult and I think it's impossible
to predict exactly how it will be for us
we we
we I mean I don't know no one knows how
it's going to be we can predict
approximately what what will happen but
we don't know how how the world will
look like and how people will behave I
don't know
it's about the in terms of the climate
deniers personal
I mean of course it's sad that people
spend their time doing something that
doesn't make any good and I don't but I
mean you just have to ignore them
because they are just desperately trying
to remove the focus from the climate
crisis to to make it become something
about me as an individual rather than
the crisis itself